if you live in the real world you've
known for a while now that Russian
actors tried to influence the 2016
election and that there were at least
attempt to infiltrate actual voting and
election systems now I've not said that
those attempts succeeded because we just
didn't have any evidence that they did
and it's important to report what we
know and not to go beyond that right
into what we don't know or if we are
talking about that it's important to
make clear that we're speculating if
it's not something that's been
officially alleged or demonstrated well
part of this story has now changed
because Jeanette Mann freh who's the
head of cyber security at the Department
of Homeland Security
she now has gone public and said that in
2016 there was not only targeting of 21
states by Russian actors in terms of the
voting systems but that some of those
attempts succeeded in penetrating our
voting systems here is Jeanette Mann
freh in an interview with NBC News take
a listen the Russians were able to
actually get inside the voter
registration systems can you confirm
that and I can't talk about classified
information publicly but for the
visibility that we did have we saw
targeting of 21 states and an
exceptionally small number of that 21
were actually successfully penetrated
and where it was coming from was not
just Russians but the Russian government
correct no doubt no doubt this is very
significant language number one there's
no doubt whatsoever about the source
which is not individuals in Russia but
the Russian government but listen to her
language an exceptionally small number
of states were penetrated if the number
is zero you say they made 21 attempts
none of which were successful
if you describe the number of successes
as anything other than zero like for
example saying an extremely small number
that means that some were penetrated the
number is more than zero this should be
front-page news on every news channel
Russians
successfully penetrated our voting
systems
in the 2016 election it is huge but
again we want to be responsible here
this doesn't mean that Russians flipped
votes we don't know that all this means
again according to the head of cyber
security at DHS that Russians tried to
hack into voter rolls in 21 states and
they succeeded in at least some of those
states did they change voter
registrations did they flip votes did
they deregister people we don't know at
this time we have no evidence to suggest
that and it actually doesn't matter
right because the mere hacking into
voter rolls itself is a sanctionable act
and remember that Donald Trump is now
twice declined to enact sanctions
against Russia further meddling in the
2016 election and if you still don't
believe this is everyone part of the
conspiracy I mean is truly everyone
coordinating to trick us into thinking
that Russia did this the United States
consensus of multiple intelligence
agencies is that this is what Russia did
did an unrelated report found that this
is exactly what Russia has been doing in
dozens of countries over the last two
decades the Netherlands did a report
themselves that has nothing to do with
the American report on Russian meddling
in the 2016 US presidential election
they came up with the same conclusion so
at a certain point Pat especially with
the addition now of the cybersecurity
chief of DHS saying yeah this is what
they did either everybody was tricked in
some kind of incredibly broad reaching
transnational conspiracy into issuing
faulty reports that Russia did this uh
or they're just lying for some weird
reason I mean there's no explanation I'm
looking at it at the point of view of
someone who is skeptical about all of
this because we are still relying on the
word of our intelligence agencies it's
the woman who works for the Department
of Homeland Security he hasn't shown us
the evidence the evidence themselves
even though 17 of our intelligence
agencies the entire community yeah are
unanimous and saying that Russia did
meddle in the election right some people
are just gonna believe it and that's
where it comes to standards and
expectations and that's why sometimes we
get calls
from people and they say I don't believe
anything happened and I say well what
would be evidence and they said I just I
just don't think Putin and Trump met and
came up with a plan it's like right
who's saying that that's the standard
we're looking for right it's also to
point out that just because they've only
found evidence of penetration so far but
not of altering votes or voter
registration that doesn't mean they
didn't do those things right absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence and
we need to keep pushing for the truth
when the stakes are this high and I want
to repeat this because it's so important
I'm not saying Russians flipped votes we
don't have evidence of that right now
what I am saying is that they penetrated
the voting systems and with this
election being so close electorally I
mean remember Hillary crushed Trump in
the popular vote electoral II this
depended on 77,000 744 votes in
Wisconsin Michigan and North Carolina
you don't have to flip much to flip the
election right a hundred and thirty
million votes were cast Oh point zero
six percent of those going the other way
in the right states swings the entire
election so all I'm saying Pat is let's
make a hundred and ten percent sure we
know exactly what did and didn't happen
given that we now know the Russians did
infiltrate the voting systems and last
thing on this once you infiltrate
flipping votes isn't the only way to
impact the election right purging voters
is another if you purge
disproportionately Democratic voters who
end up either voting on a provisional
ballot that may or may not be counted
who really knows or some of them just
get frustrated and they leave without
voting at all when it's 77,000 votes
that can also have an impact
we know that the voter rolls were
penetrated does anyone believe Russia
would go through the trouble of
penetrating voter rolls merely to look
around and do nothing it's difficult to
believe and I hope we eventually get the
full answers on this yeah when we think
about the Trump Russia investigation
there seems to have been a shift to now
well are focusing more on financial
crimes money laundering whether or not
Trump and Putin had a specific deal and
action obsession yeah and obstruction of
justice because that would affect us
policy if we're favoring the Russians
over our own sure right I wonder if this
will create an emphasis on the stuff
that we're talking about months back
like the Podesta emails and the DNC
hacks and fake news spreading because
that seems where this road goes down I
am hoping that even though you're right
that the media narrative around the
investigation has shifted in that way
I'm hoping that all along the Moller
investigation has not narrowed in in
accordance with how the media narrative
has narrowed and that he's been focusing
on this stuff in addition to everything
else you mentioned we will see major
major news not being widely reported the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership